you mentioned in one of your lectures on
virology that there are more viruses in
a leader of coastal sea water than
people on earth
in the nature article titled
microbiology by numbers it says there
are 10 to the 31 viruses on Earth also
it says that the rate of viral infection
in the ocean stands at 10 to the 23
infections per second and these
infections removed 20 to 40 percent of
all bacterial cells each day there's a
war going on do you uh what do you make
of these numbers oh why are there so
many viruses so the the numbers you're
quoting they're in my first virology
lecture right because
people don't know these numbers and they
get whoa they get wowed by them so I
love to give them so they decide to
interrupt yeah as I was saying uh
offline you have one of the best
introductory lectures on virology that
I've ever seen introductory lectures
period so I highly recommend people find
you on YouTube and watch it if you're
curious at all about viruses it it uh
yeah there's a lot of times throughout
watching it I felt like whoa yeah that's
my goal is to work and that's what my
students tell me one student once that I
every day after every lecture I could go
home and tell my roommate something she
didn't know and and blew her away so the
number of viruses is really an amazing
number so that number 10 to the 31 is
actually just the bacterial viruses in
the ocean
so there are viruses that infect
everything on the planet including
bacteria there are a lot of bacteria in
the ocean and so 10 to the 31 is from
basically particle counts of seawater
all over the world so they're more
viruses than 10 to the 31 but just in
the ocean and that number is so big
first of all the mass exceeds that of
elephants on the planet by a thousand
fold and if you lined up those viruses
end to end they would go 200 million
light years into space it's so big a
number it's it's amazing and then yes 10
to the 20 some infections per second of
these viruses killing bacteria and
releasing all this organic matter and
that's part of this what we call the
biogeochemical pump cycling of material
in the ocean the bacteria die
they start to sink and then they get
metabolized and converted to compounds
that that are needed a lot of it gets
released as carbon dioxide and so forth
so these are actually really important
cycles that are catalyzed by the virus
well it's so wild and nature has
developed a mechanism for mass murder
IA that's one way to look at it but it's
just what happened right it's
interesting I mean
um I wonder what the evolution advantage
of like such fast cycling of life
is is it just an accident of evolution
that viruses are so numerous or is it um
is it is it a feature not a bug so the
the fast is
it rain it does not all fast not all
viruses are fast some are 20 minutes per
cycle some take weeks per cycle
um but that's just per second there's so
many viruses in the ocean that that's
what you get per second no matter how
fast the cycle is but I look at it this
way viruses were probably the first
organic entities to evolve on the planet
long ago billions billion years ago just
as the Earth cooled in or organic
molecules began to form
I think these self we call them
self-replicators
they're just short things that today
would look like RNA which is the basis
of many viruses right they evolved and
they were able to replicate of course
they were just naked molecules they had
no protection and it was just RNA based
and that that's tough because RNA is
pretty fragile in the in the world and
um it probably didn't get very big as a
consequence
but then proteins evolved and I'm
skipping like hundreds of millions of
years of evolution proteins evolved
maybe without a cell maybe with the cell
but then
to make a cell there probably were some
rna-based cells early on but they were
pretty simple but the cells that we know
of today even bacteria and single-celled
eukaryotes
they have very long DNA genomes and you
need a lot of DNA to make a complicated
cell and so we think at some point the
RNA became DNA
and probably one of the earliest enzymes
that arose is the enzyme that could copy
that RNA into DNA which we now know
today as reverse transcriptase which my
former boss David Baltimore and Howard
co-discovered
and that that enzyme arose and copied
RNA to DNA and then you could build big
cells with d because DNA can be millions
and millions of bases in length and RNA
the longest RNA we know of is 40
000 bases not much bigger than the SARS
cov2